thanks and more on that developing news
he was just talking about more violence
on the strip overnight a man
gunned down outside the palazzo hector
mejia
is there live with what police say
happened and how they caught up to the
suspected gunman good morning to you
hector
good morning alex and that victim is at
the hospital in critical condition this
morning while the gunman is in police
custody and metro police arrested him
right there near treasure island that is
where police say the gunman took off
running with another man
we saw police officers still on the las
vegas strip earlier this morning and
right now
and earlier we saw one metro police
squad car right behind treasure island
and earlier we captured a bigger police
response here on the las vegas strip
with investigators telling us they
believe it all started as a fight on the
casino floor of the venetian
at least four men involved security
threw them out
right after midnight but the group
allegedly met up outside to fight again
this time that fight happened near the
palazzo and at some point the suspect
allegedly took out a gun after a
struggle
one shot went off hitting the man who is
now fighting for his life
at the hospital and again police did
make an arrest arresting at least
one man here outside treasure island
right behind us reporting live this
morning hector mejia
8 news now